[Musik]
die Gegenoffensive der Ukraine scheint
nicht richtig voranzukommen woran das
liegt und worauf wir uns alle einstellen
müssen in dieser unübersichtlichen
Weltlage darüber spreche ich jetzt mit
dem sicherheits- und
Verteidigungsexperten Carlo Masala
herzlich willkommen bei Phoenix
persönlich danke für die Einladung wir
alle spüren dass wir in einer
Zeitenwende Leben und beginnen wir
vielleicht mal mit einem ganz konkreten
Blick auf die ukrainische gegen
Offensive da haben sie jetzt diese Tage
gesagt dass eine Fixierung auf
territoriale Gewinne falsch sei warum
weil diese ukrainische Gegenoffensive
aufgrund der Tatsache dass die Ukraine
natürlich weniger Material hat als die
russische Armee weniger Personal hat als
die russische Armee nicht primär auf die
Eroberung von Territorium ausgerichtet
ist sondern sie ist darauf zunächst
einmal bis jetzt ausgerichtet russische
Verteidigungslinien zu über denen
russische Logistik zu zerstören die
russische Artillerie zu schwächen um
dann die Möglichkeit zu haben Vorstöße
zu machen ich finde wir haben medial
zu sehr von Anfang an darauf gewartet
dass sowas ähnliches passiert wie im
Herbst letzten Jahres passiert ist
nämlich die Ukraine macht eine gegen
Offensive die russische Front kollabiert
und innerhalb von ich glaube das waren
damals 48 Stunden erobern die Ukraine 70
Quadratkilometer Territorium das war von
Anfang an eigentlich ausgeschlossen die
Russische Föderation hat vier bis fünf
Monate Zeit gehabt ihre
Verteidigungsstellungen auszubauen das
hat sie sehr intensiv gemacht sie hatte
Minenfelder gelegt sehr sehr groß sind
also die Schätzungen gehen das bis zu
30.000 Minen verlegt worden sind bevor
diese gegen Offensive gestartet ist und
da war es eigentlich von Anfang an klar
dass um diese Sachen zu überwinden das
ist Zeit braucht das ist sozusagen viele
Operationen braucht die austesten wo
kann man hier durchstoßen wenn man
durchstoßen kann wie kann man zu den
Verteidigungslinien kommen wie kann man
diese Minenfelder vermeiden wie kann man
sie räumen und von daher war von Anfang
an klar es wird nicht schnell werden
also es wird keine schnelle gegen
Offensive werden es wird eine harte
gegen Offensive werden sie wird leider
Gottes sehr viel Menschen leben Kosten
und gleichzeitig ist es steht es in den
Sternen ob sie erfolgreich sein wird
deshalb auch so viel darüber gesprochen
weil ja durchgesickert ist dass die
US-Geheimdienste gesagt haben mit der
Strategie kann es nicht werden damit
wird es scheitern teilen Sie die Analyse
das ist besser gewesen wäre auf einen
Punkt sich zu konzentrieren oder
es ist natürlich wenn man sozusagen nach
dem Handbuch von militärischen
Operationen Vorgehen würde ist es
natürlich besser ein Schwerpunkt zu
haben
irgendwo die Truppen zu massieren das
Material zu massieren und dort versuchen
durchzustoßen jetzt ist aber noch mal
die Ukraine hat weniger Soldaten sie hat
weniger Material das ist eine
hochrisikobehaftete Strategie wenn das
scheitert dann hat die Ukraine sozusagen
erhebliche Verluste in ihren
Streitkräften und dann wäre diese ganze
gegen Offensive von vorne rein also
beendet gewesen der ukrainische
Verteidigungsminister hat irgendwann in
den letzten Tagen ein Interview gegeben
wo er meines Erachtens richtigerweise
gesagt hat wir wollten ja kein zweites
Stalingrad also ich habe eine
Verantwortung für Menschen ich habe eine
Verantwortung für das Material und der
muss sich gerecht werden und alles
sozusagen auf einen Punkt zu
konzentrieren was sicherlich taktisch
sinnvoll ist erstmal ähm wäre ein hohes
Risiko gewesen und wenn das schief
gegangen wäre dann wäre möglicherweise
diese Gegend Offensive schon längst
gescheiter gehören die Drohnenangriffe
auf Moskau mit zu dieser Strategie
die Drohnenangriffe auf Moskau gehören
insofern mit zur Strategie weil sie
natürlich militärische Einrichtungen
treffen wir haben auch in den
vergangenen Tagen haben wir Angriffe auf
Flughäfen gehabt wo auch militärische
Maschinen stehen und ein Viertel zum
Beispiel der russischen
lufttransportfähigkeiten wurden dabei
zerstört oder erheblich beschädigt und
lufttransportfähigkeiten sind natürlich
diese Fähigkeiten die Menschen und
Material von Russland an die Front
bringen können also von daher gehört es
zum Teil der Gegend Offensive es findet
Kräfte in Russland es trägt aber auch
den Krieg nach Russland hinein um der
russischen Bevölkerung zu zeigen das ist
kein Krieg den ihr nur im Fernsehen
miterlebt sondern dass es ein Krieg der
real ist und der euch mittlerweile auch
betrifft weil wir Ziele militärische
Ziele in der Russischen Föderation
angreifen also von daher ja es ist Teil
der Gegend offensiver
Russland Vergeltung für diese Drohnen
Angriffe angekündigt diese Nadelstiche
wenn es zum Teil war auch Häuser in
Moskau trifft
sie sagen das soll der Nachschub
sozusagen behindert werden und die
Kräfte gebunden werden wo wäre aus ihrer
Sicht dafür eine Grenze was darf nicht
passieren also was definitiv nicht
passieren darf sind zwei Sachen das eine
ist wenn die Ukraine zivile Ziele
angreifen sollte das ist sozusagen ein
Kriegsverbrechen das sollte die Ukraine
unter keinen Umständen machen weil dann
natürlich auch die Unterstützung ich sag
jetzt mal der der Staaten der Rammstein
Konferenz oder vereinfacht gesagt der
westlichen Staaten aber sind ja nicht
nur westlichen Staaten natürlich
erheblich zurückgehen würde und das
zweite was die Ukraine genauso beachtet
ist man sollte kein von Westen vom
Westen geliefert das Material für diese
Angriffe auf russische militärische
Einrichtungen benutzen weil auch dann
würde es Diskussionen in den Staaten
geben die die Ukraine mit Waffen
versorgen die möglicherweise dazu führen
könnten weil es eine rote Linie ist für
diese Staaten dass die Unterstützung
dann zurückgeht das ist für den normalen
Bürger mittlerweile schwer zu
durchschauen weswegen ist ja auch in der
Umfrage so ist dass die überwiegende
Mehrheit sich gegen eine Lieferung der
Marschflugkörper Taurus
aus ja ausgestimmt hat aus ihrer Sicht
sind die Marschflugkörper im gamechanger
wenn sie jetzt geliefert wurden nein aus
meiner Sicht ist kein einziges
Waffensystem ein gamechanger das hängt
immer davon ab wie es eingesetzt wird
und das kann gut eingesetzt werden im
Sinne dass es wirklich dann ein Vorteil
für denjenigen bringt der der diese
Systeme einsetzt und es kann schlecht
eingesetzt werden dann bringt es keinen
Vorteil deswegen ist ein Waffensystem
als solches nie ein gamechanger egal was
geliefert wird aber wenn wir jetzt über
Taurus reden Tausch gehört zu der
Kategorie von Waffensystem als
Marschflugkörper die den Ukraine helfen
könnten ähm hart befestigte Anlagen der
russischen Armee in der Ukraine
anzugreifen und zu zerstören command und
con rollanlagen zum Beispiel die dann
die Operationsführung wesentlich
schwieriger machen Taurus ist ein System
mit dem Mann wenn man es wollen würde
genauso Brückenköpfe wegsprengen könnte
und das betrifft natürlich sozusagen
alles was was mit der Krim zu tun hat
also von daher wäre es ein hilfreiches
System um bestimmte militärische Ziele
seitens der ukrainischen Streitkräfte zu
erreichen das heißt kommt die Lieferung
aus ihrer Sicht ist das ähnliche wie wir
es die ganze Zeit schon erlebt haben
auch bei anderen Diskussionen also wenn
man die Bundesregierung die verlautbaren
der Bundesregierung anhört dann wird
diese Taurus Lieferung wohl kommen also
zunächst einmal heißt es ja dass die
Bundesregierung prüfen lässt ob
sogenanntes Gio fancing möglich ist wird
immer falscherweise gesagt ob sozusagen
die Reichweite der Taurus beschränkt
werden kann das ist das ist nicht der
Punkt sondern geofancing heißt auch
bestimmte Ziele nicht einprogrammiert
werden können und das sind natürlich
Ziele in der Russischen Föderation weil
die Bundesregierung offensichtlich der
ukrainischen Regierung oder der Militär
oder beiden nicht traut
in den Verkündungen dass man Taurus nur
gegen Ziele innerhalb der Ukraine
einsetzen würde also versucht man jetzt
diese Taurus zu begrenzen nicht was ihre
Reichweite anbelangt sondern letzten
Endes was die Ziele anbelangt und
sämtliche Ziele in der Russischen
Föderation zu eliminieren wenn das
Misstrauen aus ihrer Sicht durch ist das
Misstrauen begründet also wir wissen
auch sein anfänglichen Tagen dieses
Krieges dass das wohl im
Bundeskanzleramt und ich sagte meine
Bundesregierung ein Misstrauen gegenüber
den Ukraine gab
wohin das genau begründet ist das
erklärt sich mir nicht das Misstrauen
das jetzt existiert kann ich mir nur der
Gestalt erklären dass man befürchtet
dass wenn die Ukraine letzten Endes
diesen Krieg am verlieren ist und über
Taurus verfügt dass sie dann versucht
sein könnte Taurus gegen Ziele in der
Russischen Föderation einzusetzen den
die Russische Föderation möglicherweise
dann benutzen würde also diese diese
Angriffe um gegen die Staaten in dem
Fall die Bundesrepublik Deutschland die
geliefert haben zu eskalieren und man
dann in einer Situation wäre dass die
NATO möglicherweise in diesen Krieg
hineingezogen werden würde das kann ich
mir vorstellen dass das eine ein
Bedenken seitens des Bundeskanzleramtes
ist aus ihrer Sicht ist dies Bedenken
unbegründet also haben sie diese
Bedenken nicht also aus meiner Sicht die
sind diese Bedenken sehr unbegründet
weil man ja also tausend nicht die
einzigen marschall-körper die in die in
der Ukraine existieren würden sondern
die Briten am Storm Shadow geliefert die
Franzosen am Skype geliefert das sind
alles Marschflugkörper sie haben die
Ukraine dazu bewegt gezwungen könnte man
sagen Erklärungen abzugeben bzw Verträge
zu unterschreiben so hört man es bei den
Franzosen dass sie diese
Marschflugkörper nur auf ihrem eigenen
Gebiet einsetzen und sie haben es bisher
lange getan also ein ein Storm
Körper könnte auch Ziele in der
Russischen Föderation erreichen und
bislang hat die Ukraine das nicht
gemacht alles was in in Russland
angegriffen wird aus der Ukraine wird
mit Drohnen angegriffen aus ukrainischer
Produktion die Ukraine selenski hat auch
vor ein paar Tagen noch mal gesagt würde
diese marschflowkörper nicht gegen
russische Ziele einsetzen weil sie genau
weiß dass dann die Unterstützung des
Westens nicht vererben würde aber doch
erheblich zurückgehen würde wenn das der
Fall wäre von daher sind meines
Erachtens diese Bedenken sind nicht
angebracht weil die Ukraine gar kein
Interesse daran hat diese Bedenken sind
ja auch in Frankreich beispielsweise
andere in der französischen Bevölkerung
gibt es nicht so viel ja gegen wer zu
Waffenlieferung hier wird das ja sehr
diskutiert und auch sie glaube ich
mussen sich schon mal den Vorwurf
anhören da Kriegstreiber zu sein macht
das was mit ihm
es ist in der Regel macht das nichts mit
mir es gibt Tage da bin ich sicherlich
nicht so gut drauf dann zerrt das schon
an meinem Nervenkostüm weil es natürlich
völlig unsinnig ist dass diejenigen die
für Waffenlieferungen sind Kriegstreiber
sind aber wenn man sich die Geschichte
dieses Krieges anguckt dieses jetzt 18
Monate werden in kriegels wenn man wie
viele von Anfang an gefordert haben
keine Waffen geliefert hätten dann gäbe
es keine Ukraine mehr dann wäre die
Ukraine von Russland besetzt und wir
sehen was auf Russisch übersetzen
Territorium passiert einen Verbrechen
gegen Zivilisten und von daher habe ich
ihn sehr gutes Gewissen bei meiner
Forderung nach Waffenlieferung weil das
nichts mit Kriegstreiberei zu tun hat
sondern weil das ganz einfach nur einem
angegriffen den Staat hilft sich zu
verteidigen und seine eigene Bevölkerung
gegen die Groll taten die wir Seiten
sehr russischen Armee sehen in ihren in
den von ihnen besetzten Gebieten zu
schützen
wie ist es denn eigentlich wie viel
Taurus Marschflugkörper haben wir oder
anders gefragt wenn geliefert wird sind
eigentlich in den Beständen so viele
vorhanden dass auch Deutschland bei
einem möglichen Angriffsfall
abwehrbereit wären man muss so
unterscheiden es gibt diejenigen die
sozusagen aktiv in den Beständen der
Bundeswehr sind ich glaube mit mir
selber nicht sicher das sind so um die
150 die aktiv in den Bestände der
Bundeswehr sind und es gibt diejenigen
die bei der bei der Industrie sind denn
diese Waffensysteme haben ja auch so
eine Art Haltbarkeitsdatum das heißt
also dass die Industrie garantiert dass
sie voll funktionsfähig sind bis zu
einem gewissen Punkt bis zu einem
gewissen Datum und wenn dieses Datum
überschritten ist dann gehen Sie zurück
zur Industrie und werden dann noch mal
überprüft und gegebenenfalls sozusagen
wieder funktionsfähig gemacht ich denke
wir reden über Taurus die in der
Industrie liegen und wir reden nicht
über Taurus möglicherweise bei eine
kleine Anzahl von Taurus die bei dem bei
der Bundeswehr in den aktiven bestellten
ist also Mischmasch sein so wie es bei
dem Panzern der Fall war so wie es bei
dem Mardern der Fall war da wird ein
Teil aus der Bundeswehr genommen aber
der andere Teil ist der Teil der bei der
Industrie liegt wären wir
verteidigungsbereit wären wir
verteidigungsfähig ja wir wären
verteidigungsbereit und
verteidigungsfähig wenn wir jetzt keine
Ahnung 20.000 aus den aktiven Beständen
der Bundeswehr rausnehmen und den Rest
aber aus dem Beständen die bei der
Industrie Lager es kommt ja im Herbst
ihr neues Buch raus bedingt abwehrbereit
wie fällt denn ihre Zwischenbilanz aus
zur zeitenwände also wie steht's um
unsere Abwehrbereitschaft jetzt mal
etwas weiter gefasst als nur Taurus
ich finde es steht nicht besonders gut
um unsere apfelbereitschaft aus mehreren
Gründen zum einen die sogenannte
zeitenwände die eingeläutet wurde
die wird sehr verengt auf die Bundeswehr
und die wir sehr verengt auf die Frage
sozusagen der Ausstattung der Bundeswehr
und ich glaube aber dass man im 21
Jahrhundert und auch angesichts der
Bedrohungen die wir haben Verteidigung
viel breiter verstehen muss nämlich auch
als Verteidigung der Gesellschaft und es
gibt
Angriffe auf unsere auf unsere
Demokratie auf die Art und Weise wie wir
leben die nicht militärische Art sind
also da reden wir über
Desinformationskampagnen wir reden aber
auch z.B über den schutzkritischer
Infrastrukturen und natürlich reden wir
auch über den Panzer der möglicherweise
die Grenze zwischen der Russischen
Föderation und dem baltischen Staaten
oder zwischen der Ukraine und dem
baltischen Staaten also russische Panzer
der darüber rollt und deshalb muss man
Verteidigung breiter denken die
Bundeswehr ist ein Teil von Verteidigung
dieser Gesellschaft aber nicht der
ausschließliche teil und manchmal muss
diese Gesellschaft zu verteidigt werden
und hat die Bundeswehr die geringste
Rolle weil es keine militärische
Verteidigung ist das heißt was müsste
konkret passieren aus ihrer Sicht wir
müssen Verteidigung breiter denken wir
müssen zu einer einem denken kommen in
den skandinavischen Ländern und in den
baltischen Staaten redet man von
Gesamtverteidigung die nennen das total
Defense
und die sehen dass die Verteidigung
sozusagen
gesellschaftliche Akteure politische
Akteure wirtschaftliche Akteure umfassen
muss und natürlich aber auch Militär die
tauschen sich aus die üben zusammen
da gehen Startup Unternehmen gehen schon
in Grundschulen rein und klären Kinder
darüber auf wie Sie mit Social Media
umgehen und wie sie sozusagen sich vor
Desinformationskampagnen schützen das
sind alles Sachen die wir machen müssen
das wäre eine Zeitenwende weil wir
werden nicht nur angegriffen durch
russische Panzer möglicherweise und die
sehe ich ja eher im Baltikum und den
Polen als in Berlin
vor allen Dingen angegriffen durch das
Informationskampagnen Versuch sozusagen
diese Gesellschaft zu destabilisieren
wir haben ein Problem mit kritischer
Infrastruktur die wir schützen müssen
und wir haben eine Gesellschaft die und
das kann man jetzt hier nicht als
Vorwurf machen die in den letzten 70
Jahren Frieden gewohnt war und die heute
nicht damit umgehen könnte wenn durch
Cyber-Attacken zum Beispiel
die Stromversorgung in Berlin oder in
Teilen Berlins für drei Tage nicht mehr
funktionieren würde so und das sind die
Sachen worauf wir sozusagen Gesellschaft
auch vorbereiten müssen wie gehen wir
damit um wie gehen wir damit um dass wir
vielleicht drei Tage keinen Strom haben
oder nur rudimentärstrom haben und uns
nicht gegenseitig auf der Straße nach
dem dritten Tag sozusagen zerfleischen
weil wir um den Zugang zum Supermarkt
kämpfen wo wir ein paar Lebensmittel
rausholen wollen haben sie die
baltischen Staaten und Polen eben schon
angesprochen es ist ja so dass die
Staaten jetzt Belarus aufgefordert haben
dass die Wagner Truppen aus dem Land
abziehen sollen wird das passieren
das ist schwer zu sagen und ich halte
aber also ich kann aus der Perspektive
Polens und der baltischen Staaten kann
ich sozusagen diese Sorge um Wagner
verstehen weil es Kräfte bindet letzten
Endes muss man aber sagen wie viele
Wagner Leute sind mit pregorien zunächst
einmal nach Belarus gegangen das sind
schätzungsweise zwischen drei und 5000
glaube ich manchmal hört man die Zahl
10.000 aber die hört man eher selten das
wichtig ist aber mit was für einem
Material sind sie denn dahin gegangen
nämlich mit fast überhaupt nicht das
gesamte schwere Gerät was Wagner in
Russland hatte ist Wagner abgenommen
worden und der Nationalgarde gegeben
worden das heißt wir haben zwar der
Wagner Kämpfer aber letzten Endes haben
die nicht das Material mit dem sie
wirklich eine Bedrohung für Polen und
die baltischen Staaten sein könnten und
deswegen halte ich das äh diese diese
Bedrohungsszenario für sehr übertrieben
ob Belarus die jetzt rauswirft das
besteht in den offenen Stein ich glaube
nicht dass Luca Schenker weil die Polen
das wollen die beiden ist wollen die
Wagner Truppen aus dem Lande verweist da
wird er auf Putin hören was Putin sagt
die andere Frage ist ja wird nach
brigosch ins Tod ist eine Racheaktion
der Wagner Söldner geben oder werden sie
sich eingliedern was ist da ihre
Prophezeiung das ist auch schwer
einzuschätzen aber ich würde hier auch
auf den Punkt wieder verweisen man
braucht Material um wirklich sozusagen
dieses diesen diesen zweiten
Putschversuch oder die zweite Meuterei
durchzuführen also man braucht die
Panzer man braucht das schwere Gerät
über das alles verfügt Wagner nicht mehr
fast überhaupt nicht mehr nicht mehr in
dem Ausmaße wie es eins mal der Fall war
ob sich jetzt einzelne Wagner sollten zu
so einer Art terroristischer Gruppierung
zusammen tun und klassisch
terroristische Anschläge verüben das
steht in den Stern das weiß man nicht
das kann durchaus sein aber ich glaube
nicht dass es wirklich eine eine Gefahr
für Putin und seine seine Clique
darstellt wenn jetzt auf den Wagner
nahen Kanälen in Social Media jetzt
sozusagen angekündigt wird es wird so
eine Art zweite Meuterei geben
überhaupt da nach diesem ja tot ins
Flugzeug ist er aus ihrer Sicht gestärkt
oder noch weiter geschwächts mit dieser
Aktion
ich bin kein russland-experte ich kann
das sozusagen nur aus aus einer
Vogelperspektive sagen was auffällt ist
dass die wichtigsten Kritiker Putins mit
Blick auf die Art und Weise wie dieser
Krieg geführt wird dass die jetzt alle
kalt gestellt sind also pregorian ist
tot und gehen auch aber utkin war ja
nicht so prominent sozusagen in der
Öffentlichkeit vertreten der Chef der
russischen Luftwaffe wurde seines Amtes
enthoben das der war sozusagen auch eng
mit gregorien und
iGO geldkin das ist der Oberst der die
der letzten Endes den Krieg im Osten der
Ukraine organisierter 2014 der ist zwei
Wochen vorher verhaftet worden das sind
drei sehr prominente Figuren die Putin
Kritiker waren oder Kritiker der der
Militärführung und das
Verteidigungsministers wie der Krieg in
der Ukraine geführt worden sind die sind
jetzt alle weg also Putin versucht seine
Macht zu stärken und er versucht so
sieht es aus diesen vielleicht kann man
ihn nennen extrem internationalistischen
Flügel der ihm kritisiert hat bzw die
militärische Führung kritisiert hat den
Versuch der kalzustellen ich glaube aber
letzten Endes dass die Erfahrung dieser
Meuterei auch weiterhin in Russland
wirken wird also von daher ja Putin
versucht seine Macht zu stärken ob ihm
das gelingt da bin ich skeptisch weil
diese Meuterei gezeigt hat dass es Risse
in diesem Fundament von Putin gibt was
er ja auch versucht ist auf der
Weltbühne nicht isoliert dazustehen und
die brix-staaten wozu ja Brasilien
Russland Indien und China und Südafrika
gehören die wollen ja jetzt weitere
Mitglieder aufnehmen welche Rolle spielt
das in dieser absolut unübersichtlicher
werdenden Weltordnung ich glaube wenn
man auf die bricks schaut und jetzt
diese diese diese Welle in
Anführungszeichen von von Aufnahme
Anträgen dann geht es da weniger um
Russland als China dann geht es darum
dass ich starten sozusagen eine
Organisation anschließen wollen die
letzten Endes von China informiert wird
die chinesischen Interessen dient und
die die Chinesen auch als Instrument
benutzen um ihre Position in der
internationalen Politik zu stärken also
von daher das spielt Russland glaube ich
eher eine sekundäre Rolle China spielt
die neue Rolle und das ist letzten Endes
also die bricks werden kein wir haben
das bei dem Treffen auch gesehen bei dem
letzten Treffen so viel Einigkeit
besteht nicht unter dem brexit aber es
ist halt der Versuch sozusagen näher an
China heranzukommen und für China ist
das willkommen weil die Brixen
Instrumentes um die eigene Position in
der internationalen Politik zu stärken
und spielt damit rein in die Entwicklung
die wir seit 10 Jahren sehen nämlich der
den Versuch Chinas neben der regionalen
hegemonien Asien sozusagen auf Augenhöhe
mit den Amerikanern zu kommen global
also das heißt hin zu einer neuen
Bipolarität die anders sein wird als sie
genau auf diesem Wege zu dieser
Bipolarität also in einem richtigen
macht Kampf zwischen USA und China wir
sind mittendrin in in diesem Prozess wir
sind noch nicht in einer ausgewachsenen
wie Polarität aber letzten Endes wenn
dieses internationale System sich ändern
wird in den nächsten 10 15 Jahren dann
wird es ein bipolares werden und nicht
ein multipolares wie gerne sozusagen
auch seitens der Chinesen argumentiert
wird aber auch die Bundesregierung in
der nationalen Sicherheitsstrategie sagt
ja wir befinden uns in einer
multipolaren Welt das geben die
Machtverhältnisse nicht her was wenn man
sich anschaut sozusagen wie ist die
Macht verteilt in diesem internationalen
System dann wird es entweder ein
bipolares System werden oder aber wenn
es in Amerikanern und ihrem Verbündeten
gelingt diesen Aufstieg Chinas zu
verlangsamen oder zu stoppen dann bleibt
es eine abgeschwächte unipolarität sie
haben gesagt das kluge Politik auch mit
Diktatoren verhandeln muss die wir für
ihre Taten verabscheuen der Versuche die
eigene Außenpolitik allein an
moralischen Maßstäben auszurichten und
die Welt nach Gut und Böse einteile der
wirklich Ordnung schaffen sondern immer
nur wieder neues Chaos anrichten wie
bewerten sie unter dieser ihre eigenen
Maßgabe die deutsche Außenpolitik ich
glaube ich auch deutsche Außenpolitik
machten ähm meine Sachen sehr klugen
Balanceakt zwischen in einer
wertorientierten Außenpolitik die die
Außenpolitik der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland immer war also man muss
sagen ein Großteil unserer Interessen
wenn man diesen Begriff mal benutzt der
entspringt ja unseren Werten es gibt
Interessen die wir haben die in springen
aus unserer geopolitischen Lagerung also
wir sind ein Land ohne Rohstoffe wir
brauchen Rohstoffe also von daher haben
wir ein Interesse an einem freien
Welthandel am Zugang zum Weltmarkt dass
wir einen Rohstoffe ankommen aber viele
unserer Interessen
kommen halt aus dem Grundgesetz
herauskommen aus Verträgen heraus die
wir abgeschlossen haben unsere
Mitgliedschaft sozusagen in den
Vereinten Nationen Unterschrift unter
die Karte für die internationale
Menschenrechte von daher versucht die
Bundesregierung hier eine Balance zu
halten zwischen einer Werte orientierten
Außenpolitik und eine Interessen
geleitet aus dem Politik was sie oftmals
gelingt aber manchmal ist sozusagen da
kann man den Iran Fall sehr schön nehmen
manchmal trifft es das halt auseinander
in der Schulnote muss ganz plastisch zu
machen
in vielen Minus
das lassen wir mal so stehen was mich
noch interessieren würde ist sie
befassen sich ja ihr ganzes Berufsleben
mit diesen Konflikten
haben Sie vielleicht die Fähigkeit sich
in unterschiedliche Perspektiven
reinzudenken schon im Elternhaus
mitgenommen ihr Vater ist Italiener ihre
Mutter ÖsterreicherInnen sie sind wenn
ich es richtig gehört habe in Sardinien
haben sie die ersten Jahre ihres Lebens
verbracht ist das was diese Fähigkeit
aus mehreren Perspektiven auf etwas zu
schauen was sie damit genommen haben
gute Frage würde ich eigentlich so noch
nie nachgedacht habe
nee ich glaube nicht also ich glaube
nicht dass das die Fähigkeit ist aus
unterschiedlichen Perspektiven ich
glaube also meiner Analyse entspricht
entspringt aus einem aus einer
fundierten theoretischen Orientierung
die ich habe
meine Elternhaus hat mir eher
beigebracht wie es ist wenn sozusagen
unterschiedliche Kulturen aufeinander
stoßen und wie die es schaffen oder halt
manchmal auch nicht schaffen zu
koexistieren und wie dort Konflikte
ausgetragen werden das glaube ich kommt
aus meinem Elternhaus sie haben ja
wirklich ein bilderbuchaufstieg
geschafft vom Arbeiterkind hin zum
Professor für internationale Beziehungen
jetzt an der Universität der Bundeswehr
was hat sie angetrieben dass sie da sind
wo sie jetzt sind es ist ganz einfach
mich hat überhaupt nichts angetrieben
ich bin da eher reingestolpert was mich
immer angetrieben hat war sozusagen mein
mein Durst nach Wissen und Sachen zu
wissen und das hat mich immer in der
Wissenschaft gehalten ich habe relativ
spät mich entschieden sozusagen den
Versuch zu unternehmen mich auf auf
Professuren zu bewerben bevor ich nach
München gegangen bin war ich fünf Jahre
lang am Natur die Fans College und habe
dafür einen Institut gearbeitet habe das
auch teilweise geleitet das hat fürs
military Community der NATO gearbeitet
da war ich halt in dieser thinking Welt
da wurde mir klar dieses hintank Welt
ist nichts für mich
naja es war so ich hatte da nicht die
Freiheit zu entscheiden wohin ich reise
sondern ich musste Reisen und ich weiß
für mich so ein Erweckungserlebnis das
mag jetzt ganz blöd klingen ich war für
die NATO zwei Wochen in den USA ich bin
zurückgekommen an dem Samstagabend am
Montag hat mich mein Chef ins Büro
gebeten ich dachte der wollte was über
die USA wissen das wollte er gar nicht
wissen sondern sagte die NATO macht
irgendwas mit den Chinesen zusammen die
wollen sozusagen dass ich mit in dem
Team bin dann habe ich gesagt ja okay
dann habe ich ja bald geht's los und
dann sagt er morgen
und dann habe ich mir gedacht so ich
reise gerne und das ist alles in Ordnung
aber ich lasse mir nicht sagen sozusagen
war nicht zu reisen habe und dann war
für mich dieses Think Tank Sache letzten
Endes auch vorbei nach fünf Jahren und
dann habe ich mich für Professoren
beworben aber letzten Endes was mich
immer angetrieben hat war sozusagen der
Drang zu wissen und
ja zu studieren mein eigenes Wissen zu
erweitern über Zusammenhängen in dieser
Welt gab es mal schwierige Momente auf
ihrem Weg wo sie möglicherweise sogar
Rassismus erfahren haben oder eine Form
von Benachteiligung in der Wissenschaft
selber nicht das muss ganz klar sagen
ansonsten in meinem Leben also ständig
in den 80er Jahren aufgewachsen das war
eine Zeit voller Rassismus also
Rassismus habe ich an allen Ecken und
Enden erlebt
naja das das geht über die Sprache in
den 80er Jahren normal war also ob sie
dann halt Spaghetti Fresse genannt
werden ob sie halt weil sie in
österreichische Mutter haben und in
italienischen Vater Bastard genannt
werden das sind alles so Sachen die
ihnen begegnen ob sie in den 80er Jahren
sozusagen ständig im Polizei Kontrollen
geraten weil sie schwarze Haare haben
und immer irgendjemanden ähnlich sehen
der irgendwo woanders also im
Nachbarviertel gerade Autoradios geklaut
hat Autos aufgebrochen hatte oder sowas
das waren meine im Prinzip Erfahrungen
die ich gehabt habe also von daher ja
rassismus ist mir Begegnung beruflich
glaube ich ist mir Rassismus nur einmal
begegnet da war ich vom Netto de fans
College schon weg bin aber wieder zurück
eingeladen worden
und habe dort mit einem deutschen der
ein griechischen Nachnamen hat auf dem
Panel gesessen und wenn man bei der NATO
ist dann steht dann der Name und dann
steht da das Land dass man in dem Sinne
repräsentiert das heißt dieser deutsche
mit griechischen Nachnamen und der
deutsche mit dem italienischen Nachnamen
saßen da Unterstand Germany und nachdem
diese Konferenz vorbei war kam ein doch
älterer deutscher Diplomat der in
Brüssel war bei der Ständigen Vertretung
und stellte sich vor mit seinem
urdeutschen Nachnamen und sagte dann
sozusagen das aber witzig dass sie
Deutschland repräsentieren
und das ist dann so wo man sich denkt ja
wenn du wenn du sozusagen in den 2000
und nicht begriffen hast das ist eine
ganze Generation gibt mit nicht deutsch
klingenden Nachnamen die deutsche sind
die Deutschland repräsentieren dann
lebst du noch irgendwo in den 50er
Jahren und das ist für mich so eine Form
von subtilen Rassismus von Menschen die
nicht mit die nicht begriffen haben wie
sich dieses Land entwickelt hat was ist
das für ein Gefühl mit dem was sie jetzt
geschildert haben auch mit dem was sie
als junger Mensch erlebt haben dass sie
als junger Mensch in Kontrollen gekommen
sind und jetzt einer der gefragtesten
Sicherheitsexperten dieses Land sind
das ist schon jedes mal
alles führt immer mal wieder zu
Situationen wo ich mich selber kneifen
muss und mir die Frage stelle ist das
alles wahr was da passiert ist also
überraschen
nein genugtungen finde ich überhaupt
nicht also dass das ist überhaupt nicht
sozusagen meine Einstellung es ist auch
nicht dieses ich habe es euch allen
gezeigt so ich bin in diese Rolle
reingeraten ich ähm natürlich
schmeichelt sie mir das kann ich dir
nichts anderes sagen ich weiß aber dass
ich genauso wie jeder andere ersetzbar
bin als als jemand der diesen Krieg
erklärt als jemand der sozusagen
deutsche Außenpolitik über deutsche
Außenpolitik nachdenkt oder über globale
fragen wir sind alle ersetzbar von daher
sollten wir alle ein bisschen bescheiden
sein und jetzt nicht glauben dass wir
auf dem Gipfel sind wir können genauso
schnell wieder im Tal landen wie wir
jetzt in den letzten zwei Jahren hoch
auf dem Gipfel gekommen sind mit meine
ich und damit meine ich alle anderen
KollegenInnen
die auch so eine ähnliche Rolle
einnehmen wie ich öffentlich dann
herzlichen Dank dass Sie uns einmal die
Außen und Sicherheitspolitik noch mal
ein bisschen erläutert haben herzlichen
Dank für dieses Gespräch ich danke für
die Einladung
[Musik]